[Music]
hey everybody it's monday
you got your hecho in mexico shirt on
i know i'm not pronouncing it right but
that's just what it looks like to me
yeah
yeah wait
yeah you're having portuguese
real close
yeah yeah um i wanted to give a shout
out i don't think louie is here
but i'll probably do this again like on
the main show but we got a package from
louie today
and sent us
the steel book
of the karate kid oh i never seen that
one just kind of cool
okay oh that's the original karate yeah
the original character
and this movie here called the
accountant which i actually have heard
is very very good
i haven't seen it either but i've heard
it's like really good yeah so thank you
very much louie like i said all
all in um announce again on uh the main
show
when maybe louie will be here but you
know oh i also wanted to say and i don't
think dermott is here either one of our
uk
uh fans sent us another like amazon gift
card so thank you very much he sends us
amazon gift cards like all the time
so
thank you very much for that dermot like
i said i will thank you again on the
main show
uh you know because i don't know if
you're here or not so yeah we didn't
know what movie we were gonna watch last
night so i'm scrolling through
amazon prime's free to me section
and i see this little movie here
called future world from 1976
which is a sequel to westworld now i'm
sure that when we because remember we
reviewed westworld a while back
and i'm sure that in the course of uh
you know researching that movie
that
it you know the information probably was
out there that it had a sequel
but i had forgotten
completely
that westworld had a sequel which came
out in 1976
so i was like well
i told tom i was like you we need to
watch that i think just because yeah so
i had never seen it
so uh yeah this actually i i kind of
feel like it didn't get real good um
reviews at the time
but this is actually a pretty solid
little flick i like that they took the
concept of westworld
and
took it in a slightly different
direction like there's still you know
the realistic robots that they're still
like the theme park aspect but
they kind of went like a little bit
i kind of feel like they went more with
like a 70s like paranoid thriller type
thing
like with the robot so i thought that
was like a really really good idea
so
yeah
this was actually absolutely worth
watching i liked it i did too it's not
as good as the first one but
you know i really like that like i said
that they took a they took a risk and
went like a little bit of a different
direction yo brenner shows up and it
reprised the role
of the original of the gunslinger
although i will say i i know why they
did that because yule brenner's
gunslinger was like such an iconic role
but i will say that does seem kind of
like shoehorned oh yeah definitely it's
definitely shoehorned in because he
doesn't really have anything to do with
the main plot like it was going on it
was just to get you to come see the
movie yeah i mean they basically all
they put him he's not even actually in
it he's just in it like in a dream
sequence yeah and she fantasizes that
she meets it and yeah it because she's
yeah she because she sees him like in
clips from the original uh thing
so this was directed by
richard heffron
and he did a few movies none that i had
seen
but he's probably more um better known
for doing like tv he did
a bunch of episodes of the rockford
files
and he did the original run of north and
south do you remember that one that
civil war
uh
series
so i remember watching that and he
directed that so this is one of the
handful of movies uh that he did
now i think mgm who originally did
westworld were actually gonna make this
but then it turned out that
they didn't really want to do it because
they were going to do logan's run
instead the same year and they just
thought well we're only going to do one
sci-fi movie and it's going to be
logan's run
so they passed this one off and i think
um
uh aip american international they ended
up taking it over which usually i mean i
kind of feel like american international
pictures
gets a little bit of grief for being
kind of like schlocky b movie kind of
stuff
but
this still i mean this looked like it
was fairly low budget but
not really
and i will say too that this was
actually i think
as far as uh i could determine was
actually the first
movie to use like 3d
cgi
you know what i mean yeah i didn't i
didn't see any of that yeah yeah yeah
because the one part where they were
kind of cloning peter fonda
and they had like part of him like they
had his face in his hand like the 3d
like in the computer like kind of
modeling like that
yeah so that was i as far as i know
that's the first use of like 3d cgi not
very impressive well no but it was 1976
right and if this was the first movie to
do it apparently it really kind of
wrecked her to me that they did that
they did that
this is pretty good what they they
couldn't do the same thing twice
yeah took this in into the into the
blade runner direction where they're
making replicants they're making them
out of proteins
and uh
and they'll make a total replicant of a
person which
it's pretty good it makes this is the
year before star wars
it kind of makes you wonder if uh ridley
scott had seen this
because um
the whole idea of corporations using
things like this for bad purposes it's
all in here yeah i'm kind of interested
to see because what we were talking
about last night because you said well
what about is this where they got the
idea for the replicants in blade runner
and then i was like well
do android stream of electric sheep came
out i don't remember when when the book
came out but they weren't but you said
that they weren't really replicants in
the same sense as they were in the
movies so it's very possible yeah in in
the book um they were they were robots
basically i mean they had gears and cogs
and stuff like that in them so
no
they were i mean um
deckard goes out to the [ __ ]
goes to goes out to the desert and finds
a
[ __ ] horn toad out in the desert and
he thinks it's real but
it breaks and a [ __ ] spring comes
flying out of it or something
so no it was
they they were a type of robot they were
they weren't biological
and this one it's well it seems like
this one it's a little bit unclear
because it does seem
like some of the ones are robots like
they were on the first one because they
take their faces off and it has all the
gears behind it just like in the first
one
but then i guess they're trying to
perfect more like a replicant like an
organic
uh type of thing like more like cloning
i kind of feel like they're doing that
so there's kind of both
so what the setup of this is well they
were 3d printing remember yeah yeah 3d
printing them with proteins yes way
ahead of its time they got they got the
technology right
they were using proteins to 3d print
them out
and then i don't remember how they were
how they were getting uh
the the minds into them but they could
make a replica of you
and the and not only that and like i
said i don't really know how this would
work but um
so they're essentially cloning the
people but they could like read each
other's minds
yeah you know like if you're like if
they made their mind something yeah like
if they made a replica they didn't go it
was like some whatever technology yeah
but
they kind of like
i kind of wish they'd gone a little bit
more into that because it's just like
toward the end like when the characters
get replicated
and
that it's hard to fight them because
they already know what you're gonna do
because they think the same thing as you
yeah so it i don't know if it was just
like the movie like the screenwriter
being like thinking that a clone was
like an absolute
because that you know in in practice
like a clone of you would just be like a
twin they would be able to like read
your mind or nothing but you know what i
mean i was thinking this may have may
have this would have been a big movie
when it came out a guy like ready scott
would have seen it definitely it was
this is the year before star wars this
is one of the like the top sci-fi movies
of that year
and it goes in a direction a lot of
blade runner prometheus uh blade runner
2049 or is that 49 29 i don't remember
that 24 blade runner [ __ ] two okay
that's i'm gonna call that [ __ ] all
right just out of defiance blademark two
and um aliens and alien and
you know [ __ ] prometheus
where you have corporations just trying
to replace people with their own
creations and they even come out and say
so people aren't reliable enough quality
isn't good enough
[ __ ] [ __ ] up yeah and you guys don't
don't obey
so it's just better to just make a
make a person from scratch that is
exactly what you want for your company
and and
and basically they say we're going to
get rid of y'all y'all suck okay
obsolete the whole world will be robots
and these replicas
that's that's blade runner [ __ ] two
that's probius same same concept
same you know so
now
how they were going to do it it's kind
of like james bond oligarch villains
they were opening in a new park
and they were inviting all the most
important people from around the world
and they're all showed up
and they all dressed like foreigners
they got them in foreign costumes so you
know they're from all around the world
we were laughing about that because it's
like yeah they always they did that a
lot like in movies probably even into
the 80s and maybe even the 90s where
it's like if you wanted to show like
people from foreign countries like in
one place like in an airport or
something for example they would always
put people in like traditional dress
from that country and i'm like
normal people from that country would
just be wearing like jeans and t-shirts
like everybody else on earth it's like
you're not going to walk around and
you're full [ __ ] wearing dashiki
they just want everybody to know that
they wanted the audience to know that
these people from all around they were
important people the leadership from all
around the world corporate military
leaders everything
and what and they were applying them
with coming to west world and future
world
and have sex with all these damn robots
yeah they were leaning hard into the sex
with robots
and then the idea was is that while you
were in their party and they're gonna be
taking samples from me they're gonna
copy you
they're gonna copy you
kill you and replace you with your
replica and you go back to your home
world your home country
and uh get back into your position of
power and this corporation takes over
the world through it through its proxies
like the world economic forum it's like
that exactly like that can i just say
that prior to this movie coming out
you had another
book slash movie
that
was replacing people with very realistic
robots and that was the stepford wives
yeah
uh the book came out in
late 60s early 70s and then the movie
came out in 1873
but that was essentially the same thing
i mean it was a robot i guess but
it was a really realistic robot so maybe
so it wasn't like that
you know it was kind of out there in the
cultural
conversation
and the corporation was mostly all
robots at this point
i don't think they had they even showed
any humans
in the corporation well you weren't
really sure
because you thought the top dude was a
human
turns out he was
yeah duffy yeah
um yeah so all right so what happens in
this movie now
going on from the original west world
obviously
um
you know that
the company that's behind westworld
delos
it's been a couple of years like two or
three years since this disaster that
happened at west where all those people
like all the guests and the staff got
killed because all the robots went ape
[ __ ]
so basically uh duffy who is the head of
delos
he has this big kind of like press
conference and he invites all of these
people from the media
and he's like look we've spent the last
two or three years we spent like
almost two billion dollars
revamping the whole entire park it's all
completely safe now we replaced every
single robot every single circuit there
is absolutely no way that anything can
go wrong and we're gonna make it bigger
and awesomer and you guys all have to
come there
and
you know write about it so that you can
you know because people still were like
leery of going because of the whole [ __ ]
that happened in westworld and they're
like well i don't really know if i want
to go there so they still have
multiple worlds
they still have now westworld is still
closed they actually do show like the
set of it but it's like still abandoned
but they have other sections of the park
they have like medieval world still they
have roman world they have
something called spa world which i guess
it's like it kind of has a weird
hypnotist thing where it makes you like
think that you're young again
has that and then it has future world
which
puts you in a thing where uh they do
like a simulation where you're launching
and you're kind of like uh you know in a
satellite around a planet you know what
i mean and you can like go ski on mars
and all this other kind of stuff so
yeah so that's kind of where most of it
is that but to be honest with you they
do kind of go into a little bit they
don't show much of the other worlds like
they show a little bit of medieval world
and a little bit of spa world and stuff
like for a couple of minutes and even
though the main characters the
journalists um peter fonda is like a
newspaper guy
and blythe danner is like a tv
like personality yeah peter is good in
it he is
so they uh you know get to go there and
while they're on the plane
going to the place like i said there's
all these like foreign dignitaries and
they've also been invited
to you know try this place out because
they're trying to like get the word out
about it that it's it's all safe now and
[ __ ] like that
so so they end up doing future world so
they go in the simulation like it's you
know going into space and whatnot
and then the where okay here's the weird
thing about it
this movie i know this this only just
now occurred to me this very second
the movie starts with
a game show
where this really obnoxious guy
wins like 50 000 and then he wins a trip
to
you know delos to the
future or whatever it is
and
and then like they i thought he was
going to be like a bigger character
because remember like at the beginning
like he's on the plane and like i said
he's super obnoxious and he's like
hitting on he's just committing life
danner's character and [ __ ] like that
and i thought that he was going to be
like factor more into the plot later on
but then they kind of like forget about
him i think he's supposed to be the
every man i guess like
i guess you're supposed to associate
that character with you if you're just
the average [ __ ] joe in the you'd be
like this if you went to dallas yeah man
yeah that's how i'd be
that's what that's
yeah because it just seemed like he was
just there because you know he gets to
the sex robots and
and he's like well i have to choose
which one of you and she's like why do
you have to choose you can have both of
us and he's concerned and he's like i
don't think i have enough like you know
gumption to do that or whatever it's
just like and i think after that scene
you don't see him again do you maybe he
dies of a heart attack
maybe that's maybe that far was cut out
but yeah so something was missing there
well the thing about it is okay so peter
fonda the reporter guy it's it's
interesting because i guess him and
blaise tanner's character they knew each
other previously like they worked
together previously did they [ __ ] at
some point i don't know like in the in
the previous it's kind of seemed like
they had some sexual tension going on if
you ask me
it's not that actress that character is
not very interesting that she's playing
she's just kind of a generic female
character yeah there's not much about
her
and uh she's a little bit sassy yeah but
she's a little sad interesting to me
she's kind of kind of a stereotypical
female sidekick character for for movies
of that time
kind of like kind of like a [ __ ] frog
from smoking a bandit
you know yeah she was kind of a bit like
that except not as goofball not as
goofball but just like that
um
now um
what's got what's his name [ __ ] get
his name peter father yeah peter father
peter fonda he's a young peter fonda and
he's kind of like playing a planner
playing a similar role that like a young
kurt russell would have been cast in he
was kind of like that he was that he was
at the crustal status he was at crustal
level well he's like what i was gonna
say is that there's like a conflict
between the two of them because even
though you think that maybe they had
some kind of romance in the past they
definitely did used to work together
because they make a couple of things
about that
but
she is kind of willing to take all of
this stuff like when she gets to future
world and they start looking into the
stuff because duffy the guy that runs
the [ __ ] is all like you guys can ask
whatever you want you can go wherever
you want it's like we want to show the
world that it's like safe now and we got
all our [ __ ] together and stuff and
she's kind of like willing to take it at
face value but peter fonda is like super
skeptical well he has reason to be
skeptical because you saw a dead dude
before he even goes to the place
uh this guy named frenchy like calls him
up and says hey i've got like all this
like low down info on that place and
come and meet me at this place and then
when he goes to meet him like the guy
gets shot in the back or stabbed in the
back or something like that
so he's like okay well obviously these
people are up to something so the whole
time he's like sure that there's
something nefarious going on which
obviously otherwise there wouldn't be a
movie um and she's just kind of like no
it's fine you know what i mean like most
of the time but obviously like as it
goes on she's like oh yeah maybe you're
right there is something like nefarious
going on there absolutely is something
nefarious going on by the way yeah they
find out about the plot
it takes a long time for them to
actually admit to you what what is going
on in dallas you just kind of have to
read in between the lines you know
something's going on but it takes about
a half hour before you find out what it
is they're trying to do
i figured it out like when they got
when their dinner got drugged and then
they started talking about uh dna and
stuff yeah
so i figured out what they were what
they were doing
people on the outside because the thing
about it is that one of the improvements
that they made from the original
westworld they tell the people is that
well you know um
we the reason that we think the original
westworld like while the robots went ape
[ __ ] and like killed all those people
was because there were these imperfect
human engineers who were making them and
repairing them so it was like human
error so now what they've done is not
only do you have like all the sex robots
and all of the regular robots going in
the theme park that you can interact
with everybody that works there
is also a robot like all the robots
like all the programmers and stuff like
that there's only a few humans
one of whom is like a mechanic and he
actually ends up
helping uh the journalists out like
later on almost hide now
yeah he's kind of like hiding down and
he's got an old broken robot that he
calls clark yeah clark kent man of steel
yeah
and it's kind of goofy but it's it's
it's okay
he plays cards with him and stuff
and honestly like at the end where he's
like leaving because he's like well i
gotta get the [ __ ] out of here cause i'm
gonna get my ass killed and he can't
take the robot with him obviously
the way he like was saying goodbye to
the rob was like does it that man loves
that robot yeah it was a gay
relationship between a man i mean it was
like it was kind of touching i was like
oh that was kind of sweet yeah
and the robot was crying when he left
yeah he was like oh yeah well the robot
he didn't have a face because
um he can't break it well yeah the
mechanic said you know i kind of got
sick of having to pull his face off
every time he busted because it was like
an old so he's like so i just left the
face off it's like he doesn't mind right
so it's just he's just walking around
these like [ __ ] circuits
um
it's uh
it's pretty good flick uh one of the
thing kind of stood out to me was just
the setting
it's it's some aerospace museum or
something it's uh it is it's in um i
looked it up it's in houston they shot
it pretty much and yeah the houston
space center
um it said on wikipedia i wrote it down
it's right here it's right here oh i
want to say too like you know the scene
that they did in this movie in the in
the bar
you know like near the beginning where
all the people were first in there and
they were playing like rock and soccer
robots or whatever that was the same set
as the apartment set from logan's run
okay they just like red redressed it
uh so there was that
yeah um
houston intercontinental airport jones
hall and the johnson space center that's
where it was filmed and all the
underground [ __ ] is um a bunch of like
pedestrian tunnels underneath the city
that's where they filmed it so it was in
houston
also a fun trivia for you
in 1979 future world became the first
modern american film to achieve general
theatrical release in china
isn't that strange this movie of all
which i kind of feel like has been
more or less completely forgotten about
because they did westworld then they
made this movie and then they made a
series called beyond westworld which i
don't think lasted that long
and then like late like you know
obviously just like a few years ago they
did like a west world series which got
like a lot of critical acclaim and stuff
but i think people forgot that they had
a sequel and a series back then also if
you guys never seen westworld westworld
was pretty good
um
it was a movie of its time it was it
impressed the audiences of its day
um but really the best part about that
movie was yule brenner yo brenner plays
a a robot cowboy who kind of goes
haywire and kills a bunch of people
and
if you watch
westworld and look at you old brother
you'll see that that if you ask me
that was the inspiration for terminator
the original terminator was judo brenner
he [ __ ] does a great job as a [ __ ]
android as a robot and it
and some kind of terminator type [ __ ]
goes down you know in terms of like
you're trying to fool his vision and
it's kind of a running survival type
game or a type movie where this robot's
after you and you just you can't stop it
and it's good it's a real good shot
so uh just kind of reminds me of that i
think that concept might have been
lifted out of there
as the inspiration for terminator yeah i
think we might have mentioned that when
we reviewed westworld because i was like
this absolutely and a lot of especially
like toward the end of westworld it is
like a lot like the terminator like that
character right i was wondering last
night when we were watching future world
which like i said and i'll get into this
a little bit they kind of shoehorned the
guns like nothing that i'm complaining
because he was cool but um
when did he were those contact lenses or
did they just like have some kind of
light i think it was some kind of
reflecting on his eyes it looked cool
because it looks real it's subtle but it
actually looked really like quite creepy
slightly glowing like a cat's eye white
yeah and he's had a kind of
you brunner he's in this movie too so we
can talk about him
he had a very cool look he was i believe
he's part mongolian
and they never really bring it up
there's just something kind of alien
about the way he looks he just looked
really [ __ ] cool and he's kind of a
shorter guy about my size and there's
just something weird about the way ewell
runner looked he was physically kind of
menacing for a smaller guy you know what
i mean there's something about his face
just the way he carried himself his
voice
his [ __ ] his iconic role meant to be
the king and i he's [ __ ] great it was
a musical yeah really good i wouldn't
mind re-watching that actually i haven't
seen that for you etcetera etcetera
etcetera
yeah i haven't seen that for you kind of
based on a real story evidently i think
i we watched it in high school like when
i was in chorus yeah i don't think i've
seen it since then plays the king of
siam which is a [ __ ] country that
doesn't exist anymore
it's now thailand i believe yeah um
but uh
he's he's in this movie he doesn't
[ __ ] love scene as as that robot
that's pretty good that's one thing and
like i said i'm not complaining because
it's a cool because it's a cool
character yeah and he just looks cool
and it's like of course he wanted to see
him again yeah he was the iconic thing
from the original movie so like we have
to find some way of like putting him
back in this movie so what they did
so even though the park is reopened
westworld
the westworld part is still closed and
it's abandoned so obviously they
couldn't have him in there like
organically so what they did they just
kind of showed it at the beginning
um when they were when they were in the
meeting like talking about the bad [ __ ]
that had happened at west world leaguers
before
and so you kind of get some uh footage
from westworld there but then later on
just for whatever reason well i guess it
does kind of tie into the plot what's
what you were saying about like the
clones being mind readers and stuff
the uh this company has also developed
technology
that you put a bunch of like [ __ ] on
your head like a you know thing and you
sit in a machine and you fall asleep and
it can record your dreams so like other
people can watch them
so
because they're do like i said it
doesn't have a lot to do with the main
plot
but
so blythe danner's character she's like
oh okay i'll bite i'll do it and so she
goes to sleep in this machine and she
inexplicably has a dream
in which uh the gunslinger is like kind
of coming after her but also she's kind
of like oh all right you know what i
mean yeah so there's kind of it's kind
of like he's menacing like chasing her
but then she's like oh okay i'm all
about it and he's got like a red ribbon
and it's like spinning her around and
then they're like making out and stuff
and it is bizarre because it's kind of
like arnie on a terminator as the
terminator making out with some chicks
it is pretty weird he's real awkward
about it and everything and it is it's
it's supposed to be weird though i guess
so to be weird but it was kind of true
it was kind of creepy that dream
sequence
it was kind of creepy but uh it was a
good flick um
it uh
they couldn't redo that first movie it
just wouldn't work but so they tried to
give you a little bit of europe runner
and that terminator action
but they could only do it a little side
story that dream sequence then it had to
go get back to an original story i think
look man
even though the first one is real iconic
inspired the terminator if you ask me
had a lot of good ideas in it
the first one was pretty memorable
especially in its day
i think the script on this one was
better than the first one
like i said this one had very much more
of that like 70s paranoia conspiracy
thriller type vibe to it which i think
was a good direction to go in well
another thing is is that they layered in
stuff that ridley scott would have been
all into yeah which is almost kind of
like a corporation that's trying to take
over the world like something out of
damn
007 [ __ ] specter
um it's
kind of like it's kind of like way
wayland uh industries and [ __ ] um uh
with tyrell
corporation
making robots and making
replicants and they're trying to take
over the world and they're trying to
replace the human population
with more manageable versions of humans
and better version of humans and getting
rid of our asses because we're
substandard we're obsolete to get rid of
us
and so you'll just have that's
that's what prometheus was about
and blade runner you played with our
2049. yeah so the so this movie is
basically like they're
they're trying out i guess like i said
they they'd perfected the robots because
they had all the and all the people
working there were robots but what they
were doing with this like soft launch
where they invited all these like world
leaders and whatnot to come there
because they didn't clone all of them
they just did a few they did the you
know they they did the uh the
journalists and then like a couple like
one like japanese guy like one like
russian guy or something like that
russian general and i think they just
wanted to like try it out to see if it
would work
um to see if like the the person could
pass for like a regular person so they
were trying to like start off slow so
even though say what they were going to
do with the originals i guess they were
going to kill the originals no they did
say because basically what the um clone
was programmed to do was the first thing
they were programmed to do is kill the
was the original the original right okay
and then they're supposed to just like
to go out in the world and take your
place but you'll be friendly to the
company and just do what they want right
you know what i mean like spectre right
so that's what they were gonna do but
then like i said i guess they were just
doing it a little at a time which is
probably pretty smart because if you if
they did like replaced everybody then
they'd be like what the [ __ ] uh so they
were just kind of starting with like
four people at first and maybe like to
see if it would work out yeah you know
what i mean so they do like a lot of
like cloning type [ __ ] in this so it was
very
i mean michael crichton didn't write
this he wrote the original westworld but
i guess like some of the ideas that he
came up with in the original one like
that kind of plays through into this
like i said it has a little bit of a
stepford wives kind of vibe to it too
just in the way that they're you're
replacing the print and then the clone
or the robot is like you know gonna kill
you the scope is a lot bigger though
yes because they're trying to take over
the planet get rid of human beings yeah
stafford wives was mostly just like one
neighborhood yeah or one city or
whatever yeah this is a lot bigger but
this is their school yeah they're trying
to like take over the whole entire time
the fourth industrial revolution humans
are obsolete we're going to replace them
with all these the corporations will
like that we'll have a few people but
they're just the heads of the
corporations and we shall inherit the
earth and we will have the garden of
eden that's what they're talking about
and they will all serve us
as you know like gods yeah that's the
sense we're gods and they're our
creations because that goes back to
tyrell corporation and blade runner it
goes back to [ __ ]
uh the dude in [ __ ] blade runner 2049
over there what was his name um wait uh
not waylon tyra not wayland tyrell was
what was the other one
the guy who was uh
what's the name of that company
in in blade runner 2049 i can't remember
that made the damn
it made the hologram girl
that's right i can't remember i can't
remember the name of that and he was he
was trying to do the same thing he was
trying to make more replicants
he's making replicants and robots and ai
ai [ __ ] uh
uh holograms
you guys might remember what what the
name was
yeah jason willie says michael crichton
was ahead of his time yeah yeah he
definitely he definitely was would
michael crichton work on this one too
not this one but he he wrote westworld
right
yeah and mango says have to agree in
fact his original jurassic park novel is
far better than the movie yeah it is
actually
he wrote a lot of that little like
sci-fi back in the day most of his [ __ ]
has been uh
most of his shit's been adapted to
movies you know what i mean yeah
but uh yeah so yeah this is on amazon
prime
so if you liked the original west world
and want to see a slightly different
take on it with still
it's still set in the same world but i
like that they went in a slightly
different direction with it yeah they
they took it to the next logical step
if you get a robot can you can you
produce a human and what would you do
then
yeah would you take over
yeah because as soon as they started to
start talking about dna i said oh that's
why they invited all those like
important people they're going to
replace them they're going to clone them
and replace them right i was like that's
what they're going to do you have
political power and just then you can
send the people out it's like just you
know they'll do whatever you want
because they're like under your control
type of thing but yeah so uh yeah this
is a pretty decent uh flick and it's
just funny that like i said when we
reviewed westworld i'm sure
we probably mentioned that it had a
sequel but i had completely forgotten
about it in the interim so when i came
across it i was like wait what and i was
like oh okay well we gotta watch that so
that's what we ended up watching last
night um i don't know what we're gonna
watch tonight we could either we maybe
we could watch this um the accountant or
we could find something else i don't
know we'll uh think of something anyway
but yeah we'll be back tomorrow to do
another movie review do you have
anything else you would like to add all
right thanks everybody for dropping by
and we will see you guys again tomorrow
afternoon
bye